Venom has officially latched onto theaters.
Now that we've seen what this inky symbiote
has to offer, let's break down the world-building
and story stuff that the movie leaves hanging,
as well as some big important questions that
it just plain doesn't bother bringing up.
These are the biggest unanswered questions
in Venom.
A riot going on
In the beginning of Venom, a private Life
Foundation rocketship is returning to Earth
from parts unknown, with a collection of "samples"
that we learn are fully-formed symbiotes.
As we later learn from Jenny Slate's character,
Dora Skirth, the rocket was sent on a hunt
for galactic "real estate" that humanity could
colonize.
Upon return, the crew happens to encounter
and collect the symbiotes from a passing comet
a move that backfires when one escapes, crashing
the rocket to Earth.
The crash frees a symbiote named Riot, who
begins hopping from body to body in a world
tour of the planet.
The alien eventually breaches the Life Foundation
HQ to infest the company's evil founder, Carlton
Drake.
But why?
From the start, the Riot symbiote seems to
be driving toward a clear goal.
It certainly doesn't make its way to Drake
by random chance the rocket crashes down in
Malaysia, and the movie shows every deliberate
turn the symbiote takes on its trip around
the world.
The movie never stops to explain why the symbiote
is doing this.
Why is Drake the target, and how did it come
to this decision?
Who knows — they make a fantastic couple,
though.
The losers
One of the movie's earlier laugh lines occurs
when Venom, recently bonded to Eddie Brock,
rudely identifies the down-on-his-luck reporter
as "a loser."
As Eddie and the symbiote become closer, Venom
reveals that, on his home world, he's also
something of a loser.
It's a tantalizing bit of information that
doesn't get expanded upon.
What makes Venom such an outcast on his planet?
What about him distinguishes him from his
peers?
Maybe they're just turned off by his insult
comedy, or his inclination to do good.
It's hard to say none of the homeworld politics
are really established.
Hey gotta save something for the sequel.
Alien invasion
Once Riot and Drake meet up, they get along
quite swimmingly.
As it turns out, the two villains have a bit
in common.
The movie establishes that Drake is power-mad,
trying to lead humanity into outer space at
any cost.
Completely by coincidence, Riot was already
on his way to Earth with a swarm of symbiotes
for the express purpose of conquering the
planet.
Naturally, the two villains team up, combining
their powers for mutual benefit.
The question that never gets explored is "why?"
Why are the symbiotes attempting to invade
Earth?
What gave them that idea?
Have they been here before?
Is invading planets, like, their thing, or
is it just a Riot thing?
The villains fail so spectacularly that we
may never find out.
The other symbiotes
While the crashed rocket sets Riot loose,
the other symbiotes remain in captivity, eventually
arriving at the Life Foundation none the worse
for wear.
But what happens to these other symbiotes
at the end of the movie?
It's established that the symbiotes are still
being used in experiments six months after
their arrival, and the only one we see escape
is Venom.
The others, presumably, remain in the lab
throughout the rest of the film.
One of them is even used to kill Dr. Skirth.
Venom breaks free and destroys Riot, but it's
completely unclear what happens to the other
specimens.
Are they still locked up in that lab, or do
they get out into the wild?
Are they good guys or bad guys?
Does Venom intend to go after them, or did
they just die offscreen?
Maybe we'll see a few more of these far-flung
visitors in a sequel.
The Dead Foundation
Riz Ahmed's Carlton Drake never shares a kind
word when an evil one will do.
The CEO goes out of his way to prove what
an awful person he is, constantly threatening
to kill the families of his exceptionally
loyal employees.
But his most puzzling move occurs at the height
of the movie's third act.
After fusing with the Riot symbiote, alien
and host both rush into their plan to dominate
the world.
But instead of using Life Foundation resources
to help usher along this project, the pair
decide to just start slaughtering the staff
of the organization.
Immediately afterwards, they take the fight
to Venom, ultimately losing their lives.
But what happens to the Life Foundation after
Drake is dead?
Do they disband?
Do they reveal their boss's research?
Or does someone else take over?
When the movie ends, it's all unclear and
considering the group's militant secrecy,
it's a massive loose end.
Brock is back
The movie ends with Eddie on an upswing.
After being fired by one media outlet and
effectively blackballed from many others,
it's revealed in the conclusion that Eddie's
been offered his old job back.
But how?
Eddie only loses his job thanks to a contentious
one-on-one interview he has with Carlton Drake,
which goes south after Eddie accuses him of
serious crimes.
As a result of betraying his editor's trust,
turning a puff piece into an inquisition,
he loses his job.
By the end of the movie, Drake is dead, and
the Life Foundation likely in tatters.
But how does that lead to Eddie getting his
job back?
Since getting fired, Eddie has only made his
reputation worse, showing up to his old office
as a flop-sweating nutcase.
He doesn't just freak out the security guards
he violently breaks into the building, leaving
behind a rude note and some research.
Afterwards, he goes downstairs and flat-out
kills a dozen police officers.
Would you really rehire that guy?
He may have been right about the Life Foundation,
but he never stopped acting insane.
"enh, I don't know."
Revenge of the redhead
The movie's post-credits scene picks up with
Eddie and Venom at the start of their next
adventure.
Deep in a dank, dark prison, Eddie embarks
on an exclusive interview with a notorious
serial killer Cletus Kasady, better known
to comics readers as the eventual host of
the unhinged Carnage symbiote.
The appearance is all setup for a sequel,
which would presumably see Kasady escaping
prison to cause chaos.
But the movie leaves some things ambiguous
about this encounter.
As Eddie himself details, this interview with
the killer is a big get for the journalist,
with Eddie having been specifically requested
for a one-on-one.
But why?
The tenor of the conversation seems to imply
that Kasady has some kind of master plan for
busting out of lockup.
We know he eventually gets a symbiote, but
does he know that?
Does he know about Eddie and Venom?
If so, how?
Does he know about the symbiotes and what
they can do?
If not, then why did Kasady specifically want
to talk to Eddie?
Maybe he doesn't have a reason.
If you want real answers, you just have to
cross your fingers, and hope for Venom 2.